these are the destitute families pushed
into poverty
by a 90-second earthquake
their homes belongings loved ones are
gone
now they pick through handouts so their
children have clothes
the city of adiaman has crumbled
it's people are broken
some here believe the government has
blood on its hands Mother Nature caused
this disaster but they say corruption
and flimsy building regulations worsen
the death toll
it's the result of a great neglect Juma
tells me in fact we could call this
murder
today the president visited the city
with promises to rebuild
we are trying our best not to leave
anyone under the rubble I assure you
that we will rebuild in one year
but for some it's all too late we meet
barush by the ruins of his home he shows
us the place where his mother was
crushed to death
I asked him his message for the
president
he replies
but Rush has nothing left here he'd
leave the country if he could
store they also cannot wait to go
this wreck could collapse at any moment
burying him under the rubble
but he's determined
returning with a few belongings they're
leaving for Ankara
many people have told us when the
earthquake hit it wiped out any future
this city had at least 70 percent of the
buildings are damaged there's no running
water those who can leave are getting
out
for others that isn't an option
they must find a future in this broken
place
try to rebuild a home
Siobhan Robbins Sky News adiaman turkey